n
a a une désescalade possible ou
nonon.
"P"Poutine et l'Ukraine, les fas
cacachées", Vladimir Fédorovski,
anancien diplomate et auteur rue
dede plusieurs livres sur Vladir
PoPoutine.
CoContent de vous parler.
- - Je suis ravi aussi. Ça me
bobouleverse énormément cette
sisituation parce que j'ai
l'l'impression que toute ma viet
bobousiller. Mon père était
ukukrainien, dans ma famille ily
a a 11 personnes qui ont péri à
StStalingrad, et toute mon actin
didiplomatique est détruite. Nos
avavons construit un monde sûr,
auaujourd'hui on assiste à une
nonouvelle guerre froide d'empie
paparce que vous comprenez que
dadans la guerre froide, il n'ya
plplus de règles. On assiste à n
clclivage en deux blocs. Un
clclivage d'une part occidental.
PoPoutine a renforcé. La cohésin
ococcidentale et l'OTAN a renfoé
enen quelque sorte Poutine le
popouce dans les bras de la Chi.
AlAlors la Chine, la Russie, il
irira blocs entiers occidentale
avavec l'Iran. Tout ça, ça me rd
trtriste et je suis déchiré.
- - Et vous dîtes, et vous venez
dede le dire, c'est pire que los
dede la guerre froide parce que
jujustement, il n'y a plus de
rrègles. Il n'y a plus de carte
roroutière. On est dans l'inconu
tototal.
- - Bien sûr. Vous savez, j'ai
paparticipé à la création de la
sésécurité européenne. Tout état
dédétruiuit. Tout ça, vous savea
prpréfigure quelque chose de trs
dadangereux. Vous ne ressentez
papas, mais comme je suis
prprofessionnel de la diplomati,
vovous comprenez, pendant la
guguerre froide et de la
prpropagande. Mais il y avait à
ccôté des la politiques réelles.
QuQui était menée par les gens
hyhyper professionnels.
FiFinalement, aujourd'hui, non
seseulement il n'y a pas de
rrègles, mais il y a un mélange
dede genres entre la propagandet
lala politique. C'est désastreu.
C'C'est très, très grave. Nous
n'n'avons pas beaucoup
d'd'instruments. Vous savez, ily
a a trois solutions. Je tiens à
vovous le dire gravement. Il y a
lala solution de la guerre
momondiale avec les armes
atatomiques ce qui n'est pas à
exexclure ce que, vous savez, il
n'n'y a pas de dialogue. Il n'ya
plplus de contact. Les gens
prprennent décision par la base
ererronée. Il y a des sanctions.
LeLes sanctions, j'ai beaucoup
ététudié. Les sanctions ne
dodonneront pas à votre sens
rérésultats que vous pensez.
AuAutrefois, ils vont perdre la
momotte de leur pouvoir d'achata
trtransformation de l'économie
c'c'est grave pour les Russes ms
ilil y aura une répercussion sur
l'l'Occident. En Europe, ça va
cocoûter 10 fois plus chères le
gagaz. Choc pétrolier. C'est trs
didifficile à prévoir. Il y a ue
sosolution que je soutiens
bebeaucoup à titre personnel, ue
sosolution de fermeté d'un côtét
dede l'autre côté une solution
cocomme ce que le président Macn
apappelle une longue et difficie
dédésescalade. Moi, je souligne
cecela et même je tiens
àà faire un appel vraiment à une
rerencontre immédiate entre le
prprésident ukrainien et le
prprésident Poutine ce que vous
cocomprenez, les contacts, je ne
sasais pas mon expérience, ne
dodonne pas les choses
nénécessaires.
- - Très bien, et on le souhaite
ququ'il y ait des pourparlers.
MaMais si Monsieur Poutine dit n
ararrivant ne pas vrai pays, je
coconsidère qu'il doit y avoir n
chchangement de régime parce qul
a a déjà traité de régime dit, e
pepeut donner Poutine pour que s
dedeux sauvent la face?
- - Moi, je considère qu'il y a
unune base de négociation. Vous
cocomprenez, le président parlat
dede statut neutre de l'Ukraine.
PoPoutine, dans le contexte
acactuel, a toujours proclamé qi
nene veut pas occuper l'Ukraine,
cece sera une mission de courte
dudurée, mais vous comprenez ce
ququ'il faut éviter. Les Russes,
dadans leur for intérieur, ont
peperdu 25 millions dans la lute
cocontre les nazis. Ils sont
cocontre la guerre. Ils n'auront
papas accepté les choses. Il y a
unune chose très grave
auaujourd'hui.
- - Mais est-ce que vous pensez
quque Monsieur Poutine reculerat
sisi Zelensky disait: très bien,
jeje vous promets que Lucas ne
fefera jamais parti de l'OTAN.
EsEst-ce qu'on n'est pas déjà
dédépassé ça?
- - non, il n'y a pas d'aternate
àà cela. J Je conseille vraimen,
c'c'est pour ça que je appuie le
prprésident Macron. Il a parlé
avavec Poutine encore une fois.
NoNous n'avons pas beaucoup
d'd'instruments. La situation et
plplus grave. Moi, j'aime beaucp
cecette ville, Kiev, mais si
dedemain et les combats de la re
dede Kiev, c'est une chose
grgravissime. Il y aura beaucoup
dede perte, des Russes, des
ukukrainiens. Ça me déchire
cocomplètement. Et franchement.
LeLes Russes soutiennent Poutine
ffêtent entrer Claire. Les Russs
onont l'impression pour l'insta,
mamais quand il y a des pertes,a
sisituation peut changer. Ce que
jeje dis immédiatement la
rerencontre avec entre Poutine t
ZeZelensky.
- - L'ancien diplomate en vous
dédéclinant qu'on ne voit pas
nénégocier un retrait des troups
rurusses. Il y a encore une voie
popour trouver un accord entre
l'l'Ukraine et la Russie.
- - Bien sûr. Nous n'avons pas
bebeaucoup de solutions.
AuAutrement, on va simplement
fafaire des postures. Vous
cocomprenez, dire qu'on soutient
lele peuple ukrainien et ne rien
fafaire, ce n'est pas suffisant.
LaLa guerre mondiale, il faut
l'l'éviter. Alors la sanction et
unune chose ne donnera pas plus.
JeJe suis inquiet pour l'Europe,
frfranchement. Regardez la bour,
ilil y aura des répercussions
mamajeures. C'est pour ça que je
sosoutiens Macron.
- - J'ai une question pour vous
ququi connaissais bien les arcas
dudu pouvoir à Moscou. Est-ce qe
leles sanctions, qui sont quand
mmême sans précédent, est-ce que
PoPoutine lui-même pourrait être
memenacé par les oligarques quie
didiraient, savez-vous, n'a pas
enenvie de perdre des milliards
papar jour?
- - non. Les Russes sont ravis e
leles oligarques soient spoliés
papar l'Occident. Il ne faut pas
vivivre dans le monde imaginair.
VoVous comprenez, les Russes, iy
a a tendance aujourd'hui, ne sot
dede crispation. Je suis
bobouleversé parce qu'il y a des
prproblèmes avec la liberté de
prpresse. Tout ça, c'est une
chchose, il ne faut pas qu'on
rrêve, mais en même temps, ce
ququ'il faut éviter ces
mamaintenances l'effusion du sag
etet après comprendre que la
papassation imaginaire de Poutie
sesera beaucoup plus facile. Vos
sasavez, on a réussi à sortir du
cocommunisme. Comment?
paparce qu'il n'y avait pas de
coconfrontation. Un conseil,
esessayons maintenant, dans
l'l'immédiat, l'effusion du sang
etet après je suis certain que
cocomme dépendant de la
dédémocratie, tôt ou tard la
dédémocratie viendra aussi en
RuRussie.
- - Quand vous entende. Vous avz
écécrit plusieurs livres dont un
ququi m'intrigue, cette allée
trtrouvait, vous dîtes: la vraie
hihistoire.
- - C'est un livre pour oubliera
trtristesse de notre époque.
- - Justement, ça me fera du bin
àà nous replonger. Merci de nous
avavoir parl